Hey you. My name is
Thomas 'TomSka' Ridgewell,
and I am the best Tom.
And this is my channel,
and I set this up.
So I'm the best Tom.
That is your opinion.
And it's wrong.
Can you tell we tried to do the
intro for this five different times,
and then we just used your default one?
I mean, it's just,
it's very natural.
I love talking about myself.
Because I'm the best Tom.
I hate talking about myself.
And I'm also apparently
not self-confident enough
to even like jokingly say
I'm the best Tom.
You don't need to talk about
yourself, 'cause you have ideas,
but when you run out of ideas,
it's real easy to
fall back on yourself.
I'm dry as a bone creatively,
so just, it's me time.
We're gonna play board games,
and the winner is the best Tom.
That's it. That's the video.
Let's figure it out.
Yep.
Game one!
Right, so we should
probably shuffle these.
We should.
Yeah, that would be a
very short game.
Oh, it's a fresh pack as well.
Yep, not anymore.
Alright.
I'm trying not to get them sweaty.
I think if we match
on suit or number...
Jesus, it's a lot
to keep track of.
Snap, take em off to our side.
Whoever's got more at the end
of the match gets the point.
Beautiful.
Alright.
You wanna go first or second?
There we go.
Done.
(bleep)
(laughs) I'm gonna have to bleep this.
Oh, yeah. Okay.
We, yeah. I can't not swear.
It just comes so naturally.
Alright. I'm already losing.
♪ (light acoustic music)
Snap!
I did it!
I feel like you let me.
You didn't— I wasn't—
That's four hearts in a row.
It is. I did try
to shuffle it, alright?
Gy-dah!
Yes!
Didn't even move.
Oh, okay.
Fixated on the suits.
I mean, on one hand it doesn't matter,
'cause it's a YouTube video.
On the other hand, it is my
entire validity as a human
that's at stake right now.
I think I got cocky
'cause I won that last one.
I think I got desperate
'cause I didn't.
(light grunt)
I think. Okay.
I was hoping.
The ace threw me off there.
Ow. Yeah.
That one really hurt.
Yeah, you.
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god.
No.
It's gotta be so tight right now.
No, you're ahead.
I'm doomed.
It's on you.
I've gotta win this.
I gotta win this. I gotta win this.
This is the most important thing ever.
We're both— We're both—
Gah!
Okay, okay.
I'm only looking at the suits.
I can still do it. You fool.
You arrogant fool!
Nope, okay.
Well.
Oh god.
I think it's still—
You wanna count it out?
Yeah.
One.
22.
(music ends)
25.
Son of a gun.
26.
Four in it.
Damn, damn it!
Those four cards are in it.
Dammit!
That's fine.
That's game one of nine.
Okay, I was like, "We have to
play this nine more times?"
Nope, that's one point.
Son of...
Game two.
See, now I'm overconfident.
Now I'm challenging.
I know.
Now I'm threatened, so.
Oh, okay.
I can be psyched out.
Alright, let's...
So about two years ago,
middle of the lockdown,
I remember looking up
an article that was like,
"The best strategy for Connect Four."
It's a solved game.
And I looked at that and I went,
"That's too complicated.
It's the middle of lockdown.
I can't be bothered to
learn this right now."
Phew.
Yeah, yeah. If you'd just done
game theory on that,
I'd just give up now.
It's a solved game.
If you play against a computer,
it can win or draw every time.
Oh.
But I do not know
what that strategy is.
Good. Good.
So I'm just gonna be winging it.
Right.
Connect Four, I feel like the
rules are, they haven't changed.
Yeah, yep.
You connect four.
I don't know
who's meant to go first.
Yeah.
But you are behind, so you choose.
Oh, thanks.
First or second?
No, please go ahead.
Alright.
Show me how it's done.
(whispering)
I don't know how it's done.
I want to go here.
You're gonna go full anime,
like, "Hehe, rookie mistake."
No, Tom, please.
♪ (light acoustic lounge music)
Sure.
I mean, it was worth a try.
Yeah.
Wouldn't it have been
amazing if I just let you?
"That's it, over."
Why did I even put it there?
There was no hope.
I was wondering.
There was no...
Yeah, sure. I'm smart.
Come on!
Sorry.
Oh!
Not actually sorry.
I've killed myself.
I think I've killed myself.
Not entirely.
I mean, there's so many avenues
you now have to just ruin my day.
(lethargic rasp)
You can, you can...
Oh god, oh god.
This is gonna be a short one.
This sucks.
(thru laughter)
I screwed up so bad.
This is...
There's nothing I can do.
I'm not sure.
It's, either a draw—
It's not!
Like there's, you can—
It depends on how many
spaces there are.
If I put something there,
it's just immediately over.
Yeah. But you might be able to
force me to play those.
I would, I hope so.
Which is why I'm trying
to set up something else.
Yeah.
Oh, this sucks so hard.
Sorry.
This is rubbish.
I don't...
Yeah, that's there now.
I just, all I can go do
is go up.
Oh, stop.
Stop it.
Come on, give me something.
Thank you.
There, I'm on the—
Oh wait, no.
I think...
that just lost you it.
And I think it was that move
that did it, because...
I've now got two I can
win on, instead of one.
I'm not sure if it was
inevitable or not.
I feel like it probably was.
No, hang on.
I'm wrong. I'm wrong.
'Cause now...
You have to do one of those,
which means I get to at least
block one end of that.
...Yes?
But then you can...
Yeah, but now I— yeah.
Yeah.
(music ends)
But— Oh damn, okay.
Someone's gonna do an
in-depth game analysis of that,
and I don't—
Where— Oh, it's over.
It's over.
I just, I wanna keep going.
So... (cackling)
Come on!
Game three!
It's over.
Ohhh!
Okay.
I'm worried I'm gonna break this.
I feel like, yeah, do we go
for one hippo each or...?
Oh.
Or do we do two hippos each?
I think, now you've said it.
Yeah, two hippo time.
Launch all the marbles
by pressing the black buttons.
Whoever's birthday is
next gets to yell go.
Two months ago.
It's mine.
Now gobble the marbles
as fast as you can.
Whoever chomps
the most marbles wins.
(chuckling)
Okay, alright.
Alright, launch the marbles.
♪ (dramatic swell)
Oh, okay.
We gotta do that. Alright.
3. 2. 1. Go.
♪ (upbeat drum-and-bass)
Marbles!
Gimme them!
(grunt)
(music halts)
Okay.
That was very quick.
We have one more marble.
Okay.
I have nine.
Don't start, don't count now!
You have nine.
Are you kidding me?
It's all down to this marble.
It's down to this marble.
It's down to this marble, Tom.
Come on!
This is for all the marbles.
Quite literally.
I just wanna make sure
it's nicely balanced.
Okay.
May the best marble win.
♪ (drum-and-bass resumes)
Go!
(music ends)
Yes!
I win one!
Finally!
I was so tempted to flip this board.
I was like, "Do I? No, I don't."
Yes, I do!
(shout)
I mean, it's your place.
You're gonna have to
clear up the marbles.
It's fine. They're all, it's fine.
BOGGLE?!
(wheezing giggles)
Wow!
How do you play Boggle?
Just so you know, Tom,
the crew picked these games
without consulting...
I'm good at this one.
So they don't know that
you are Boggle world champion.
In 2003.
If I lose this, I will be
very angry at myself.
Cool and good.
As long as you're not
very angry at me.
But you won't, 'cause
I don't know what this game is.
Okay. So how this works is:
You shake.
And then you have to make
as many words as possible...
by connected or diagonal paths.
So you could have— That's a—
I am outta practice at this.
It's not a valid word
'cause it's a name,
but you could have Chris.
Okay.
If that was slightly
different, you could have...
We don't always get
what we want, okay?
I nearly said 'crispy'.
And that wasn't even
a deliberate mess up.
That was, no.
No.
You know, I was really
confident at the start.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
You get more points for longer words,
and we'll figure that out later.
If you can get like a seven
letter, it's worth loads.
Do we only get to submit one word,
or is it as many words as we can?
As many words as you want.
But if we both write the same
word down, it cancels out,
just to make the scoring easier.
Whoa, okay.
We need DM screens
or something here,
but honestly I don't think...
We really do.
Oh.
Yeah, that works.
I can't see your paper.
Sure.
I can't see the Boggle board,
but that can be over there.
There we go.
Yeah, you do the lid.
I'll do the timer.
Alright, three, two, one...
♪ (upbeat funk music)
Three letters is your minimum.
Is 'meep' a word?
(music fades)
(raspberry)
Don't look at— (bleep) you.
It's just awful.
That was the worst.
Shut up, okay?
Do we even have to go
through this next,
about what we got through?
We're good.
Is 'luxe' a word.
I really hope it is.
Yes?
But I put an E at the end.
I dunno if that counts.
I didn't get that.
Oh, thank you.
I didn't get 'peer' either.
Yes!
I didn't get 'rad'.
You didn't get 'red'?
That's 'red', oh.
Yeah, yeah, 'red'.
You did get red!
I got red.
It's right there!
I got 'red' and I got 'hex'.
You got 'hex'?
Oh yeah, cross 'em out.
Let's count up, shall we?
Let's see now.
Oh yeah.
As the only person with
a piece of paper.
I have won by default.
This is Displate's factory.
So many people bought their metal posters
last time they sponsored this channel,
that I thought I'd actually come over and
show folks how they're manufactured.
When you place an order for a
Displate, it's custom made here.
They print designs from video games,
comics, NASA, directly onto metal.
Or there are beautiful original
pieces from talented artists.
After printing, they'll add the
gloss or matte coating,
optionally frame it up,
then bundle it up
with their fancy
magnet mounting system,
so you don't need any tools
to put it up in your home.
And you can also get
their 3D magnets,
so the posters seem to
hover away from the wall.
It's all packaged up for delivery
and sent out
to one of their two and a half
million customers.
So if you want something
like that on your wall,
or you're looking for a Christmas present,
Displate's Black Friday deal is on
with up to 42% off
until the end of the month.
Right, back to the show.
Alright.
Oh boy.
This'll be interesting.
This is wobbly.
This is gonna be interesting.
Alright, Jenga, okay.
Which comes in some kind of fancy,
bougie box now.
Ooh, there's a thing now.
Wow.
"Edge of your seat fun."
The bourgeoisie has got to Jenga.
You wanna go first or second?
I don't— Yeah, I can—
It doesn't really make
a difference, I think.
Alright.
♪ (driving techno music)
The real drama kicks off.
You are a sick man.
I mean, I'm tempted to.
Yeah, okay.
I'll just start with that one.
I was tempt— yeah.
I was tempted to
start with the side one.
Yeah, that would've
been very, very funny.
Okay.
(shuddering)
(giggles)
This needs dramatic music.
This just needs, we gotta
ramp up the tension here.
♪ (switch to slow dramatic music)
Come on, please.
That's resting on it.
You're fine. You're fine.
You gotta believe in yourself.
We are just gonna take out all the...
All the easy middle blocks.
There isn't a block
below here that's—
There isn't a row below here
that's got three left.
Okay.
Every row from here down...
Yep, is untouchable now.
Yep.
(music intensifies)
Don't.
But you have committed.
Is that how that works?
Have you committed to the piece?
I think you can change.
No.
It's fine.
Rules said you could change.
We actually looked at
the rules of Jenga.
It has rules.
Ah...!
Let it stabilize.
Oh, this was a mistake.
I can't push it back in.
You can.
Do it, go on, do it.
No, don't do it. Go on.
Maybe towards you,
rather than...?
I want no part in
whatever's happening here.
No!
How could you do this to
our poor little building?!
I have won.
Game six.
Let's go.
Nice.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, is there a strat—
I feel like there's probably,
there's a logical strategy to this.
There is. And unfortunately,
I think I do know it.
I hate the way you are.
Yeah.
Every day you choose
to be this way,
and you could stop at any time.
No, I couldn't!
The thing is, I know
some strategy for this.
I dunno ship placement strategy.
Yeah.
We have to announce
when our ship is sunk, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Do we? Yeah, probably.
Okay, who goes first in this one?
Sure.
Thanks.
Heads.
It's a tail.
Okay.
Just get political.
Your shot first.
Sure.
I'm gonna go with...
♪ (funk music)
I-1.
Miss.
Oh, come on!
Ugh.
That's a miss.
Okay.
Miss.
Miss, dammit.
Miss though.
Miss.
B-2.
It's a hit.
Sorry, Tom.
No.
Not again.
D-8.
Is a hit.
Yes!
You have hit a ship.
B-1.
Hit, yeah, sure.
Are we at D-7?
Hit.
Yeah, I thought so.
What, do I look horizontal?
You do.
B-3.
Just a very horizontal kind of guy.
Yeah, weirdly enough, that hit.
Yeah.
And you have sunk my little guy.
Okay.
Hit.
I still have not sunk anything.
Oh, I'm getting a big boi!
D-5.
It's a hit and
you sunk my battleship.
Shocker.
Like the name of the game!
Yes.
Nah, it's a miss.
Miss.
That's a miss.
I wanna go with E-1.
Is a hit.
Yes.
Yu-us!
But that is a miss.
It's a miss.
Miss.
Let's try F-1.
Hit.
Whee.
He's going down.
He's yelling timber. E-2.
E-2 is...
That's a hit.
Big day.
I've completely messed up
my search pattern here,
I've just realised, but I'll take it.
Big day for you.
Okay, well then, G-1.
Is a hit.
Yeah, it is.
And then finally H-1.
Is a hit and you sunk a ship.
Oh, I've dropped it.
I've got the wrong strategy here.
Let's go with G-7.
Is a miss.
F-2.
Is a hit.
Have I sunk anything?
You haven't.
H-8.
Is a hit.
Yey.
I have just realised how
badly I've messed this up.
Have you though?
Yep.
'Cause I think you're fine.
If we had a confession cam thing,
this would be the bit where
I'd walk off and explain
exactly how and for what reason
I know I've just lost.
I don't know if you have.
Whose turn is it?
Yours.
G-2.
Shockingly you've hit.
But not sunk.
He's still going.
Let's go with H-6.
H-6 is a hit.
Shockingly.
It's not a sink.
Oh, I'm getting your big bois.
(music halts)
Wait, what?
And that...
is how I know I've just lost.
Oh, you've got my big bois.
Wait.
Oh, so I have more
small ones than you.
Wait.
Wait, did I—
I did the H-5, right?
You have not yet
done the H-5.
Oh, you grouped them.
Okay, fun.
♪ (funk music resumes)
I'm gonna go with G-8.
Is a hit and you have
sunk my two-length ship.
Oh no!
I dunno what it's
actually called, okay?
I'm just calling it
the two-length one.
I'm sure they've got
names in the fancy book.
Oh, you really did group them.
Okay.
I've only got one ship
left now, so I will sink—
Hopefully I-2 sinks a...
Yes, yes it does.
You did it.
I mean, the good thing
for me is
you've gotta hit a ship
somewhere.
There's only one left.
I've got three targets here.
I-10.
It would've been
really funny if you just...
Yeah, it would've been great.
But you've missed.
Damn it. That would've
been wonderful though.
That would've been great.
Oh.
F-6.
Ooh, it's a hit.
Okay.
B-4.
Is a hit.
Ehehehehee.
That's the game.
That's gotta be the game.
Finish it!
F-8.
Oh you did it, you sunk a little boy.
I sunk your four, didn't I?
There was a stowaway on that ship.
A little boy is dead.
C-4.
Is a miss!
Oh damn!
Oh no.
I've got two turns, maybe
three left, if I'm lucky.
You can do this.
H-4.
H-4 is, you're not gonna
believe this is a miss.
Agh!
Let's go with B-3.
Is a hit.
Oh no!
That's a shame for him.
H-6— No, H-7.
H-7 is...
It's not, it's just not the vibe.
And you know what?
Let's go with...
Shall I, or shall I just
start going somewhere else?
Let's go with B-5.
(music ends)
That is the game.
Wo-o-ow!
Yeah!
Three games remaining.
Oh boy.
And it's three all.
Yeah.
So none of that made any difference.
No, it was all pointless.
I mean, nothing.
Game seven!
Great.
Which rules are we going with?
Oh, I don't know.
Alright let's look at
the actual rules of Uno.
And now, a graphic about
♪ (brief jazzy sting)
We're house ruling this, then?
Yeah, we can stack.
We can stack.
Is the thing.
So the only change,
if I play a +2 or a +4,
you can bat one back at me.
Yeah.
Alright.
♪ (lo-fi ska music)
Yes.
Five, blue.
Plus two.
I'm on the offensive immediately.
Stop it. Well then,
I will be on the offensive.
That was a really
bad decision on my part.
I didn't think that through at all.
I was just like, I'm
gonna come out the gate.
Oh, I haven't got one to
back that up with, have I?
That was a mistake.
The statistical probability
that I would have a +2 in my...
Yeah, no, I realised that
the moment I played it down,
that I've made a mistake there.
Who goes after a +2?
I think you do. I've drawn.
I feel you should play.
Okay.
Nine.
Nine?
Give you a six.
Okay.
Four.
No, I love six.
Yellow.
One.
Three.
This is going very badly for me.
Eight.
Two. Down to Uno...
(giggling)
Two.
(music halts)
(uproarious giggling)
That was so fast!
(wheezing)
"This game will go on
for half an hour.
"This will just last all day."
Wow! That was the
perfect game of Uno.
That was incredible.
I had no other moves I could make.
I went wrong at the start by going,
"Oh, I'll just hit him with a—"
Oh no.
Ah, what a rush!
I lost that.
That was devastating.
That was, everything you
did set me up for the next card.
And I had no other choices
anywhere through that.
Yeah, you shifted colours at
just the right time, every time.
Wonderful.
That was the worst game of Uno.
That was the best game of Uno.
That a person has
ever played in history.
Yeah, that was lovely.
Wow! 3-4 to you.
Oh god. Now I feel bad.
I gotta throw the next
one just to keep it tense.
Oh god, this is match point.
Yeah.
I'm feeling cocky now.
That could be my undoing though.
I've gotta win this one.
You do.
Alright.
You do, we gotta keep the stakes high.
Game eight.
(both laugh nervously)
Movies.
I think you might have this one.
Maybe. I mean,
this is the thing though.
Wouldn't it be great
if I lost this one so hard?
Okay, so we're just gonna do...
The simple party game version, right?
The simple, the really short,
name movies until you panic.
Okay.
So there's a category.
You have to name the
movie in that category,
and hit the buzzer before it runs out,
and it just goes back and forth.
Yeah, so it'll be a card is drawn.
So for example, movies where
someone goes to jail and—
Shawshank Redemption.
Yeah.
So you'd hit that and then the
timer starts for 15 seconds.
And I say The Rock,
'cause they go to a jail.
Yeah, okay.
And then I hit it.
The timer starts and then it
keeps going until one of us goes,
"Oh god, oh I know this,
oh god, oh no!"
And then it's over.
How many are we playing to?
I guess just one.
I mean, we've done
one of everyone else,
and we can do best of three.
I mean...
No, you're right.
We just gotta shuffle the deck
and go for one here, haven't we?
I've gotta win this.
You do.
I've got to win this.
And I should win this,
'cause I've seen movies.
Yeah, you have way more.
I am not good on film knowledge.
I feel like your mind is gonna be better
at drawing trivia memory to the forefront.
Alright.
I think I'm more likely to panic.
We have got movies that
are more than 40 years old.
Oh my god.
(timer ticking)
Gone with the Wind.
Okay.
Some Like it Hot.
The Italian Job.
I think the original
ones was in the '60s.
Yep.
♪ (dramatic synth pulsing)
40 years ago was 1982.
So anything—
A Hard Day's Night.
198— Oh, gross.
Okay then. The Omega Man.
Yeah.
I think.
I know, it doesn't seem right.
Train Arriving at a Station.
(cackling)
Birth of a Nation, if we're going to—
Oh, really?!
Well look, I just, I know it's old!
Ah, that's 1970s.
The Titch— The Titfield Thunderbolt.
There are just so many movies.
32 steps— (bleep)
How many steps is it?
Some Like it Hot. Jesus.
I already said it!
You did?
I did!
(music halts)
(bleep)
Yes!
Oh, no, no!
Technicality!
I was going to go for
Carry On Doctor.
Knock out the entire
Carry On franchise.
But it doesn't matter.
Ohh! No!
Why would I say that?!
Oh.
That's four all.
So, none of that mattered.
No.
It's all down to the final game.
How many times
I need to explain to you
that nothing matters anyway.
We've just... we've...
What's the word? We've...
Killed time, delayed the inevitable.
I was gonna say, like,
held our own end up, you know?
Had some fun, yeah.
This doesn't count for anything.
It's not like we actually
prove who's best Tom.
And yet I really, really
care about this now.
It is important to me.
It's really...
Game nine.
Oh god.
Ohh!
No. No.
No.
God.
Ohh.
Okay.
Brilliant.
Rock, paper, scissors.
Do we have to do
best of one here?
Yeah, I think so.
We have to do best of one.
Of course we do. Of course we do.
Oh my god.
Okay, now we've gotta
psych each other out.
We've gotta try and figure out
what kind of person
the other one is.
Important stuff.
Are we going
1, 2, 3, throw...
or are we going
one, two, throw?
1, 2, 3, throw.
Yeah.
It's not like 1, 2, 3.
Anyone who does
on three is unhinged.
Okay.
(quack)
Sure, okay.
♪ (dramatic swell begins)
I'm ready.
Do we— are we both
doing it at the same time?
Is that how that works?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, this sucks.
This sucks so hard.
This sucks.
Sucks so hard.
I am more nervous about this than
other things I've done on this channel.
'Cause it's...
This is important.
This is really important.
Okay.
Sure. Okay.
Alright, I'll let you count in.
1, 2, 3, throw.
Aaah!
Yeees!
(triumphant shout)
So.
You threw scissors earlier.
I did intentionally do that.
I saw that.
In the hopes that
you'd pick that up
and then think that was
what I wanted to do.
Yeah.
So I threw rock thinking
you were double bluffing.
No.
And wanted me to throw paper.
I threw scissors thinking
that it would make you
think I was gonna throw scissors.
Though I threw paper, thinking...
Your game.
Me, Tom.
Me the Tom, yay.
Ohh!
And now a trophy!
♪ (triumphant orchestral music)
THIS IS THE BEST DAY OF MY LIFE!
I mean, this is
the best day of my life
at a suitable recording volume.
It says "Battle of the Toms
Winner 2022."
I was thinking so hard about that.
Delightful.
I'm so— Thank you.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]